the idea of capacity our biology
evolution you've talked about it
defining essentially our capacity our
limit and our scope can you try to
define what limited scope are and the
bigger question do you think it's
possible to find the limit of human
cognition
well that's an interesting question it's
it's commonly believed most scientists
believe that human intelligence can
answer any question in principle I think
that's a very strange belief if we were
biological organisms which are not
angels then we our capacities ought to
have scope and limits which are
interrelated can define the state terms
well let's take let's take a concrete
example your genetic endowment
determines that you can have a male in
visual system their arms and legs and so
on but it and therefore become a rich
complex organism but if you look at that
same genetic endowment it prevents you
from to have developing in other
directions there's no kind of experience
which would yield the embryo to develop
an insect visual system or to develop
wings instead of arms so the very
endowment that confers richness and
complexity also sets bounds on what it
could but what can be attained now I
assume that our cognitive capacities are
part of the organic world therefore they
should have the same properties if they
had no built-in capacity to develop a
rich and complex structure we would have
understand nothing I forget just as if
your genetic endowment did not compel
you to develop arms and legs you would
just be some kind of a random amoeboid
creature with no structure at all so I
think it's plausible to assume that
there are limits and I think we even
have some evidence as to what they are
so for example there's a classic moment
in the history of science at the time of
Newton
there was a from Galileo to Newton
modern science
davell
on a fundamental assumption which Newton
also accepted namely that the world is
the entire universe is a mechanical
object and by mechanical they meant
something like the kinds of artifacts
that were being developed by skilled
artisans all over Europe gears levers
and so on and the other day their belief
was well the world is just a more
complex variant of this Newton to his
astonishment and distress proved that
there are no machines that there's
interaction without contact his
contemporaries like liveness and Huygens
just dismissed this as returning to the
mysticism of the Neo scholastics a
Newton agreed and you've said it is
totally absurd no person of any
scientific intelligence could ever
accept this for a moment
in fact he spent the rest of his life
trying to get around it somehow as did
many other scientists that was the very
criterion of intelligibility for say
Galileo or Newton the theory did not
produce an intelligible world unless he
could duplicate it in a machine he said
you can't there are no machines Annie
finally after a long struggle took a
long time scientists just accepted this
as common sense but that's a significant
moment that means they abandoned the
search for an intelligible world and the
great philosophers of the time
understood that very well so for example
David Hume in his comeon to Newton wrote
that it was the greatest thinker ever
and so on he said that he unveiled the
secret many of the secrets of nature but
by showing the imperfections of the
mechanical philosophy mechanical science
he left us with he showed that there are
mysteries which ever will remain
treason can't solve put it aside we only
look for intelligible theories Newton's
theories were intelligible it's just
what they described wasn't well what I
feel oxid the same thing I think they're
basically right and if so that should
something about the limits of human
cognition we cannot attain the goal of
development of understanding the world
of a finding an intelligible world this
mechanical philosophy Galileo to Newton
this good case that can be made that
that's our instinctive conception of how
things work so if the infants are tested
with things that if this moves and then
this moves they kind of invent something
that must be invisible that's in between
them that's making the movement noise
yeah we like physical contact something
about our brain makes makes us want a
world like that just like it wants a
world that has regular geometric figures
so for example Descartes pointed this
out that if you have a an infant who's
never seen a triangle before and you
draw a triangle
the infant will see a distorted triangle
not whatever crazy figure it actually is
you know three lines not coming quite
together or one of them a little bit
curved and so on we just impose a
conception of the world in terms of
geometric perfect geometric objects
Alvin shown that goes way beyond that
that if you show on a tickets to scope
let's say a couple of lights shining you
do it three or four times in a row what
people actually see is a rigid object in
motion not whatever's there that's we
all know that from a television set
basically so that gives us hints of
potential limits to our cognition I
think it does but it's a very contested
view if you do a poll among science
it's impossible we can understand
anything
you